in the late autumn of 1833
a violent storm lashes the south coast
of england
deep black clouds race low as howling
wind and rain drive horizontally against
the cliffs
lightning rents the sky illuminating
just for a moment
a lone figure battling against the gale
skirts billowing in the deluge she picks
her way carefully between mighty hewn
rocks on the seashore
occasionally pausing backtracking
she is searching for something amidst
the sands
[Music]
just ahead of her the now saturated
rocks of a mighty cliff face
begin to crumble against the storm's
relentless assault
splitting and crashing down onto the
beach below accompanied by their own
thunderous din death for anyone
unfortunate enough
to stand below
but our figure doesn't flee from the
danger
as the dust settles and the rain begins
to ease
she calmly determinedly strides forwards
towards the cliff's wreckage
atop massive shattered boulders she
stoops to pier
at the fresh surface of limestone at her
feet
and on that surface embedded within it
an eye peers back at her
[Music]
the hollow eye socket of an ancient
prehistoric sea creature
entombed in the earth for 200
million years
in this way mary anning the daughter of
a cabinet maker
became one of the first and most
influential
paleontologists in history
this wasn't the first skeleton from the
deep past she'd uncovered
and it wouldn't be the last
ichthyosaurs and pleosures
contemporaries of the dinosaurs
being found in southern britain in
abundance
once a shallow sea home to a vast
diversity of life
all those millions of years ago
[Music]
today we know this starkly beautiful
landscape
as the jurassic coast
in order to find fossils here in the
decades before
darwin anning battled not just the
british weather
and poverty but academic indifference
too
for then creationism still reigned
supreme
not to mention as a woman in the early
19th century
it was nigh impossible for her
achievements to be recognized by the
overwhelmingly
male dominated scientific community
nevertheless today she is widely
credited with some of the earliest
discoveries of ichthyosaurs
pleosures and pterosaurs helping to
revolutionize the growing field of
paleontology
in the process as well as spawning
a popular nursery rhyme
[Music]
doubtless mary anning's discoveries were
remarkable
and though old the fossils she found are
a mere
200 million years old
they document a jurassic world where
dinosaurs ruled land
air and sea
with more than 3 billion years of
evolution preceding them
they are a late chapter in the story of
life on earth what then
of these preceding years what records do
we have
of the organisms that lived before
can we find the first pages of the book
of life
the fossils from the very first chapter
where life was just getting started
[Music]
tracking down these first fossils has
taken 200 years of paleontological
discovery
and study
scientists have scoured the globe
developing brand new techniques
in a singular quest for this
undiscovered tome
what began with mary anning braving the
english weather in order to make a
living from selling stones
continues to this day a search
for the very earliest fossils of our
[Music]
world
[Music]
[Music]
aside from the challenges mary anning
faced in finding recognition for her
discoveries
her job was a relatively easy one the
fossils she sought
were large well-preserved and abundant
in the limestone
cliffs near her home
[Music]
when she uncovered a fossil skull like
other scant references of colossal
monsters pulled from the earth in
antiquity
it was clear from its appearance that it
was indeed a skull
albeit of some mysterious creature long
extinct
[Music]
but the deeper in time paleontologists
probe
the harder their task becomes
the further back in the record we go the
creatures become
increasingly bizarre until it becomes
ever more difficult
to distinguish fossil from rock
particularly past 500 million years ago
when life becomes much more simple
what traces can we expect to find of
some of the earliest life
on earth billions of years
before our time
[Music]
in order to do so we must consider
exactly
how a living organism comes to be
immortalized in rock
at all encased in a tomb of a billion
years
when a living organism be it animal
plant or even microbe
dies biological and chemical agents move
quickly
to devour it fungi and bacteria
recycle the precious carbon breaking
down soft tissues
and leaving nothing behind
for creatures with hard parts like bones
teeth and shells made from minerals like
calcium and phosphate
these are a bigger challenge but
eventually these two are broken down
to serve the great cycle of life
[Music]
so to be preserved as a fossil a dead
creature must be entombed
sealed away from these ruthless
scavengers
before they have a chance to act
organisms that fall into sediments
deposited at the bottom of oceans
lakes rivers and marshes stand the best
chance of escaping consumption
[Music]
surrounded by mud and sand these remains
are buried deeper
and gradually as geological forces kick
in
loose sediment is transformed into solid
rock
any organic structures within become a
template for petrifying minerals
preserving the shape of the long dead
organism as rock
within rock in this way the remains of
once verdant forests
millions of years old can be seen all
over the earth
[Music]
yet despite their apparent permanence
rock repositories are not
immortal over vast periods of geological
time
tectonic forces shift landscapes around
the earth's surface
folding solid rock plunging fossils
deeper or raising them
into high mountain ranges
the rocks and the long dead life forms
within
are crushed cooked and contorted out of
all recognition
sometimes they are destroyed altogether
subducted and melted at the base of the
crust
or shattered by the elements they're
exposed to at the surface
therefore the older a rock the more of
these convulsions it will have witnessed
down the eons and the more likely it is
for it to be altered or destroyed
in other words the older a fossil the
rarer
it becomes in fact the odds of finding a
fossil of the earliest life on earth
are vanishingly small
[Music]
that organism whatever it was must have
ran
a 4 billion year gauntlet of chemical
and biological scavengers to avoid decay
without any mineralized shell or other
hard parts
its inert organic matter must have been
entombed within a matter
of mere hours the right minerals must
have been present
to encase and preserve the delicate
minuscule structures
within the accumulating sediments
and then when the rock is formed it must
withstand billions of years of tectonic
activity
without alteration
through the creation and destruction of
continents the rise and fall of oceans
too much heat or pressure or alteration
at the surface
all threaten the faint echoes of early
life
locked inside the crust
[Music]
discovering those first echoes those
first
fossils is a tall order indeed
in the search for the earliest fossils
on earth paleontologists must
look within the oldest rocks and yet
though the earth is more than 4.5
billion years old
there are only a handful of places on
earth where rocks
older than around 3 billion years remain
even
rarer are places where the rocks haven't
been cooked
or squeezed beyond all recognition
one of those places is in the brutally
arid badlands of western
australia
named north pole by the 20th century
miners who once toiled here
a reflection of its stark remoteness
but in all other respects this patch of
the australian outback
could not be further removed from its
arctic namesake
this is a desolate landscape
with one of the hottest climates in all
of australia
dusty red terrain studded with rounded
tufts of spinifex grass
innocuous at first glance but laden with
tiny silica needles that rip into
clothes and skin
fieldwork here is treacherous and
geologists rarely wander far from their
reinforced four-wheel drives
lifelines to the outside world
there are no roads out here and this is
kangaroo territory
yet this barren landscape is a great
benefit to the prospecting
paleontologist
with little water and vegetation the
rocks are exposed
and in good condition
and among them are kind known as apex
they are dark-colored glassy rocks made
of almost pure silica
with a little carbon trapped inside they
formed from a kind of
gel that accumulated on the sea floor
long ago
under conditions very different to today
the nearby rocks help to add context to
these mysterious ones
reconstructing them reveals an ancient
shallow sea
surrounded by volcanic islands the
church
formed on this prehistoric sea floor
amidst hot mineral-rich hydrothermal
fluids
circulating upwards from roiling magma
chambers
within the crust
[Music]
and by measuring the isotopic ratios of
minerals in the surrounding volcanic
rocks
geologists can pinpoint the precise age
of the church
3 465
million years old this is an extremely
rare window on an earth just one billion
years old
a time when much of what is now
australia rested
on primordial sea floor
the vast age and excellent preservation
of these ancient apex cherts
is remarkable but that's not all that
makes these rocks special
for they also contain the oldest direct
evidence
for life on earth the first
fossils
since life at this time three and a half
billion years ago
is still finding its feet it hasn't yet
advanced beyond the microscopic
in order to find those fossils
paleontologists examine
paper-thin slices of the chert with
powerful microscopes
embedded inside the chert asteride
crystals of silica
sit tiny structures made from flecks of
carbon
tubes and hollow balls each a hundredth
of a millimeter across
sometimes arranged in chains
they are remarkably similar in both
shape
and size to modern bacteria
[Music]
just like marianning's vertebrate
fossils were similar to living
vertebrates
so these microscopic structures are
similar to microbes
that live today however
simply matching shapes isn't enough to
prove that these scraps of carbon were
once alive
especially when the shapes themselves
are so simple
with the label of oldest fossils hanging
in the balance
they must be proved beyond all
reasonable doubt
to have been created by biology rather
than the inanimate earth
carbon itself doesn't signify life it is
an element born in
space within the molten core of stars
and is distributed all over the earth in
various forms
chemical transformation can create
specks of black carbon
like those in the apex charts
as for the shapes tubes and balls are
not
complex forms and could be created by
entirely abiogenic processes
it's practically impossible for physics
and chemistry alone to create an
ichthyosaur skull
but a simple microscopic ball of carbon
isn't so hard
as crystals of silica grow they can push
the specks of carbon along at their
edges
gathering and concentrating them when
many crystals join
the carbon at their margins begins to
resemble
filaments and nodes that look remarkably
like
these putative microfossils
[Music]
so in order to verify the structures as
created by life
we need more supporting evidence more
clues
that point to the hand of biology in
these ancient rocks
[Music]
the first hint can be found by taking a
step back
from the microscopic world of carbon
tubes and balls
to examine the larger scale structures
of the cherts
around north pole
[Music]
because these glassy rocks aren't
uniform
and featureless in places they're made
up of
fine layers that sometimes bend
and buckle upwards these structures
are reminiscent of stromatolites layered
dome-shaped structures built by mats of
bacteria
as they grow from the sea floor
stretching upwards
towards the light
[Music]
today modern stromatolites are rare and
are only found in any numbers
coincidentally on the western coast of
australia
at shark bay elsewhere grazing animals
destroy these bacterial megastructures
before they can take hold
[Music]
but in the ancient seas without grazing
animals
stromatolytic metropolises were much
more
common finding their characteristic
dome-shaped fossils
hints at the thriving microbial
community
that gave them form
there are other processes that can
create similar laminations in ancient
rocks
and which don't necessarily need
microbial intervention
domed layers on the apex church do not
on their own
imply life but their abundance alongside
the carbon microfossils
strengthens the case
a final clue to corroborate life comes
from
chemistry interpreting the chemical
compositions of such ancient rocks is
fraught with difficulty
as alteration over billions of years or
contamination during study
can completely change the result
[Music]
so it's taken decades of careful high
precision testing to uncover what
scientists now consider to be the
smoking gun
for life in the apex church
it's well known that life is picky when
it comes to its carbon
on earth there are two stable forms of
carbon with different numbers of
neutrons in their nuclei
carbon 13 is very slightly heavier than
carbon-12
and living things preferring the easy
option will preferentially pick the
lighter carbon for use in its cells
so scientists can measure the ratio of
carbon-13
to carbon 12 in organic matter
and find it's relatively depleted in
carbon 13.
and when paleontologists measure the
ratio of carbon 13 to carbon 12 in the
organic structures of the apex chert
they find that these too are depleted in
the heavier version of the element
something has favored carbon 12
and that something is likely life
[Music]
just as with the stromatolite-like
layers life isn't the only thing that
can fractionate carbon in this way
there are some obscure chemical
processes that favor
the lighter form alone in such
ancient rocks this chemical signature
would still be up for debate
however alongside the carbon
microfossils and the domed layers
the characteristic carbon ratios help to
make a compelling case
for life
now after years of field work in the
unforgiving australian outback
and decades of rigorous study and
cross-examination
scientists have reached a consensus
that the apex church do indeed contain
the earliest fossils on earth
but what of the first billion years
of the earth
[Music]
today the fossils in the apex church
show us that
even three and a half billion years ago
life had colonized enough of earth's
shallow seas to begin
leaving a trace they may be the earliest
fossils
but they are by no means the earliest
living things
so could there be a record of even
earlier life
yet to be discovered
if there is it will be even more
difficult to track down
and verify than the apex microfossils
older rocks are incredibly rare and
invariably
more tortured twisted out of all
recognition
and besides the biology we are looking
for is even more simple
and harder to distinguish from mere
chemistry
but that hasn't stopped paleontologists
from trying
although no other place brings together
discrete lines of evidence like the apex
chert
there are tantalising hints that could
point the way to an earlier fossil
record
in even more ancient rocks
not far from the outcrops of apex church
near north pole in western australia
there are rocks that are around 15
million years
older than our oldest fossils
these are not shirts however but layered
sedimentary rocks
such as might be deposited on a coastal
mud flat
and within these rocks on the ancient
mud flat surfaces
are tufted patterns and textures which
scientists believe
were produced by microbial mats
we still find mats like these in
estuaries today
not so extravagant as a dome
stromatolite but extensive
nevertheless
although the textures in these older
rocks are compelling there is no
prospect of additional clues here
although sediments were deposited
rapidly enough to make molds and casts
of the mats patterns
conditions weren't conducive to
preserving the organic fossils
themselves the microbes that formed them
were recycled back before they could be
embalmed in silica
disappearing back into the ether
similar structures were recently
revealed in even more ancient rocks
this time near the original north pole
greenland a land that couldn't be more
different to western australia
is famed for its ancient rocks but until
recently
they were not considered a good prospect
for paleontology
the issuer greenstones are among the
oldest rock outcrops in the world
at 3.7 billion years old
but they are metamorphic
they have been crushed and cooked beyond
recognition
and hints to their original composition
have been lost
forever
but in 2016 newly melted snow
revealed an unanticipated treasure
a section of the issuer rocks that had
somehow escaped
the destructive transformation
here the rocks preserved some of their
original sedimentary features
and among them curious conical
structures
that some scientists interpret to be the
beginnings
of stromatolites
unfortunately although the structures
have escaped to the ravages of time
the organisms if they were indeed
involved
have not there is no organic matter
left in the issue of rocks and the
chemical signals
so clear in the apex church are
controversial
in greenland with such little
information
the case remains open
[Music]
an even more tenuous hint can be found
not in rocks
but inside individual minerals
while the most ancient rocks may have
been destroyed by uplift and erosion
some vestige of them remains in
especially resistant materials
called zircons
zircons can be plucked out of an older
rock as it wears away
to then be incorporated into younger
sedimentary rocks
as they form one such zircon was
discovered
like so many ancient paleontological
clues
back in western australia although the
rocks from which it was collected are
around 3.3 billion years old
the zircon recycled from an older source
is much older
it formed 4.1 billion years ago
and contains tiny flecks of carbon
trapped as the crystal grew
that carbon contains the characteristic
depletion of heavier atoms
known to be created by living things
it's a sign that life was already
fractionating carbon
more than 4 billion years ago
but a single mineral can contain no
further information
there are no microfossil structures only
isolated flecks
and there are no layered rocks only this
one surviving
time capsule from an unimaginably
ancient earth
[Music]
on its own the smoking gun is little
more
than just smoke
[Music]
more recently still scientists reported
microfossil-like structures in the rocks
of northeastern canada
these rocks appear to be deposits from
ancient hydrothermal vents on the sea
floor and have only been slightly
metamorphosed
so some of their original features
remain
within them there are tubes and
filaments formed from iron minerals
that are very similar to modern day
microbes and younger fossils
in these settings
but no carbon remains and the discovery
is stymied by another problem
we can't be sure how ancient the
structures really
are age estimates for these rocks span
half a billion years if they are
biological in origin
they could be 3.8 or as much as
4.3 billion years old
such uncertainty and the lack of other
evidence
stands in the way of these putative
fossils replacing the apex church
on the podium
so for now our safest bet is with the
apex chert
although scientists continue to scour
test
and probe the rocks in every
inhospitable corner of the globe
searching for even deeper echoes of life
on earth
with the next snowmelt or rockfall we
hope
to discover more tantalizing clues to
the mystery of life's origin
on our planet
next time we investigate the immense
invisible magnetic forces which
shaped and continue to shape our world
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth don't forget to like and
subscribe
and let us know what you think in the
comments we'll see you next time
you